I'd like to welcome everyone on behalf
of Carnegie Mellon to the first Robo
Bowl Carnegie Mellon is a great place
for this of course you know that we're
very interested in robotics and have the
robotics Institute is one of the largest
academic organizations and robotics in
the world and also we're a school that's
become sort of strongly interested in
entrepreneurship and startups and move
worked hard as a as a university to make
policies that were friendly to our
students in our faculty encouraging them
to start companies to commercialize
their own work in various different ways
and so roll bowls are very consistent
with those two themes and I'd like to
thank the sponsors of this which have
been mentioned and also to Bill Thomas
fire and Patty wrote for all their work
and sort of driving this forward and
making it happen welcome to everybody
and glad to have you here and I at least
know an organization the room and that's
in some ways intentional we try to
operate in stealth mode and the two and
a half official years of our existence
and the three years of our unofficial
prior existence as bill said where the
private side of a public-private
partnership with the National Science
Foundation or missions promoter
country's economic competitiveness in
the global economy by promoting our
nation's innovation I in a robotics
technology consortium the other
co-organizer of today's event is a
nonprofit industry organization created
to speed the transition and deployment
of robotics technology for the Defense
Department and other government
organizations the RTC actually helped
originate the Robo Bowl concept in
response to a suggestion by the White
House Office of Science and Technology
Policy who suggested that a national
competition for next-generation robotics
technology startups in early-stage
companies might comprise a key element
of a national robotics initiative so
over the decades there'd be many many
research programs in robotics swamps of
robots dancing robots juggling robots
abound but the aunt that mini robot that
that meet practical user needs and there
are even less robots that meet practical
use in
at a place that people are willing to
pay for them and that's the big thing
that's missing in to drive this industry
forward today we're focusing on health
care and quality of life but you know
robots are transforming a lot of
industries from agriculture to military
to transportation cleaning fulfillment
centers space exploration manufacturing
disaster relief and there's just so many
the list goes on and on this is such an
exciting technology and I can't really
imagine working in a more exciting space
even after doing it for 20 years but let
me tell you the top 5 reasons why the
White House is excited about this you
guys ready for this number one prizes
and competitions there have been a
couple of big public competitions that
have attracted a lot of attention so
much attention that there's now special
congressional language saying this is a
cool thing you get a lot more work out
of starving undergraduates if you offer
them a prize it looks like you get a lot
more work out of starving startup
companies if you offer them a prize
there's currently 125 of them going on
funded by the federal government number
for public-private partnerships I don't
know if you guys have looked at the
budget situation in DC DC can't fix this
nation's problems just by coming in and
dumping a boatload of money the best way
to fix these is by working between the
public sector and the private sector
part of that is why I'm here the best
ideas don't start in DC and go out they
start out of DC and come in so I'm here
listening the notion that NSF is working
with the private sector here that's cool
we want to make that happen more number
three robots of course I think that
robots are cool but did you know that
the president thinks that robots are
cool someone says the difference between
the US and China is that in China Bill
Gates is brittany spears and in the US
britney spears as britain experience
we have to get the kids of this world
excited about Bill Gates and what better
way to do that than robots the president
said you know when somebody wins the NBA
basketball championships they get
invited to the White House I think that
the people who win the science fair
competition should get invited to the
White House so he's done that the only
problem is they scheduled him for like a
five minute photo op and 45 minutes
later he's saying now why did you use
treads instead of wheels on that robot
and show me again the turret and which
were the sensors and they're saying sir
on the ambassador of am India is waiting
it yeah but look at this cool robot the
president likes robots number two
economic growth we could use some
economic growth in this country there's
a lot of in the popular press about how
small businesses generate a lot of jobs
that's true but small businesses also
lose a lot of jobs and big businesses
generate about as many jobs of small
businesses it's the small startups that
generate a lot of jobs that's cool you
guys are up too important stuff and of
course we don't want you to be small
businesses we want you to be big
businesses we hope this is a good step
toward it finally the reason why this is
cool is because this is the way we
change the way that we live i'm a
professor i generate papers and graduate
students and that's good but papers and
graduate students don't change the way
that we live it's getting those idea
it's getting those people into companies
turning those into products that's what
changes the way we live and that's why
what you're up to here today is cool